Welcome to The Explainer.
Today, we're digging into an
argument that completely flips
the common narrative of the war
in Ukraine on its head.
The source we're exploring says
that to understand the explosion
of 2022, you first have to find
the fuse.
And they argue that fuse was lit
decades ago.
You've heard this a million
times, right?
It's the story we all heard back
in February 2022.
And the source we're looking at
today argues that this story is,
well, it's convenient, it's
simple, it's easy to digest.
But it also intentionally
ignores, you know, decades of
history leading up to that
moment.
And that really gets to the
heart of it.
Did this all just start on
February 24th, 2022?
I mean, if you hit rewind on the
history tape, what do you see?
According to the source material
we're covering, the answer is a
big, emphatic yes.
A different picture does emerge.
They say the seeds of this thing
were planted way, way back.
OK, so where do we start?
Well, our first stop is a whole
series of really explicit
warnings.
And these weren't just from
Russian leaders.
What's maybe more surprising is
that some of the loudest
warnings came from very seasoned
American diplomats.
And we're not talking about
subtle hints here.
These were screaming red flags.
Yeah, take this one.
You might think that came from
someone in Moscow, right?
Nope.
That's George Kennan.
If you know your history, that
name is a big deal.
He was the guy who literally
wrote the playbook for America's
Cold War containment strategy.
And way back in 1997, he was
already calling NATO expansion a
massive historic mistake, one
that he predicted would
absolutely provoke a bad
reaction from Russia.
All right, let's jump forward to
2008.
Listen to how blunt this is.
That's not just some opinion
piece.
That's a direct quote from a
diplomatic cable sent straight
to Washington by William Burns.
You know, the guy who was the US
ambassador to Russia then and is
now the director of the CIA.
I mean, you can't get much
clearer than that.
And it's not like the Americans
were just reading tea leaves.
A year before Burns even sent
that cable, Vladimir Putin
himself stood up at the Munich
Security Conference and
basically said it out loud to a
room packed with Western
leaders.
The point being made here is
that he wasn't being coy about
it.
He spelled it out for everyone.
So let's put this on a timeline
to see what was actually
happening.
You can see how NATO kept moving
east.
In 99, you have Poland, Hungary,
and the Czech Republic.
Then in 2004, bam, the Baltic
states join right up on Russia's
border.
But the real kicker, according
to this analysis, is that 2008
Bucharest declaration.
That's when NATO put it in
writing.
Ukraine and Georgia will become
members.
They basically walked right over
that brightest of all red lines
we just talked about.
All right, So if 2008 was the
moment the promise was made, the
source we're looking at argues
that 2014 was when things got
real.
This is where the story shifts
from warnings and red lines to,
well, what the author calls
direct intervention.
And this leads us to a pretty
central, and let's be honest,
very controversial claim.
In this analysis.
The argument is that the 2014
Maidan uprising, it wasn't this
purely organic, spontaneous
thing the source alleges.
It was actively assisted,
shaped, and even orchestrated by
Washington.
So where does a claim like that
even come from?
Well, the article points to this
number, $5 billion.
That's the figure that Victoria
Nuland, a top US diplomat at the
time, openly said the US had
spent in Ukraine since 1991 to
support its, quote, democratic
aspirations.
So the source is really asking a
question here.
Was that just innocent democracy
building or was it more of a
long term play to pull Ukraine
away from Russia and into the
West's corner?
And then there's the infamous
leaked phone call.
You might have heard about this
one.
It's where you can hear Victoria
Nuland talking with the US
ambassador about who should be
in Ukraine's new government and
what's her take on the guy who
would become Prime Minister.
Yachts is the guy.
The source presents this as
Exhibit A, arguing this isn't
how diplomacy works, it's how an
empire picks its players.
To really drive this point home,
the author uses a pretty stark
analogy.
They remind us that US Senator
John McCain literally stood on a
stage with protesters in Keith.
And then they ask us to flip the
script.
Imagine a top Russian politician
showing up in, say, Ferguson
during the Black Lives Matter
protests.
How would that have gone over in
the US?
The source suggests we'd all be
calling it what it is.
Foreign meddling, plain and
simple.
So what happened after 2014?
Well, according to this
analysis, it definitely wasn't a
peaceful, happy transition.
Instead, it was the beginning of
a whole new chapter, a brutal 8
year long war in eastern Ukraine
that frankly, a lot of the world
just forgot about.
And here's the crucial next step
in the timeline.
After the pro Russian President
was forced out in Kiev, the
Donbass region in the east of
the country basically exploded
into conflict.
The new government in Kiev sent
in the army and a bloody civil
war kicked off between Ukrainian
forces and Russian backed
separatists.
And the cost of that forgotten
war was just huge.
Look at this #14,000.
That's not a guess.
That's the number of people the
UN and other international
observers say were killed in
that conflict between 2014 and
the end of 2021.
So for eight years before the
big 2022 invasion, people were
dying in trench warfare, from
shelling, from sniper fire.
It was already a war zone.
And that right there is the core
point of this section, the idea
that February 2022 was the start
of the war.
While this author says that just
a racist, almost a decade of
bloodshed.
In this view, 2022 wasn't the
start of a war that came out of
nowhere.
It was a massive, terrifying
escalation of a war that had
already been going on for a
long, long time.
OK, so after all that decades of
warnings, the turning point in
2014, the 8 year war.
What's the big picture?
In this last part, we're going
to look at what the source says
are the big contradictions and
the major consequences of all
this Western policy.
The source points out something
kind of strange about how we
talk about Russia in the West.
It's like there are two
different Russias.
On one hand, you hear it's a
paper tiger, right?
Just a gas station masquerading
as a country with an economy
smaller than Italy's.
But then in the very next
breath, it's this existential
threat that's about to roll its
tanks all the way across Europe.
The analysis basically asks, So
which one is it?
It suggests these narratives are
just switched out for whatever
is convenient at the moment.
And the consequences of these
policies, according to this
analysis, they've been pretty
huge and maybe not in the way
that was intended.
The argument is that it's pushed
Russia and China into a tighter
alliance.
It's speed up the rise of a
multipolar world with groups
like bricks, and it keeps this
cycle going where we seem to
need a manufactured adversary, a
new bad guy for everyone to
focus on.
You know, the whole idea of this
comes down to one word really
provoked.
And it's important to be clear
what that means.
To provoke something doesn't
mean you justify what happens
next.
It just means you deliberately
poke and poke and poke at
something until you get a
reaction.
And that's the lens this offer
is asking us to use when we look
back at the last 30 years.
So that's where this all lands.
After laying out the decades of
warnings, the direct involvement
in 2014, and the eight years of
war in the Donbass, the source
leaves us with one big question.
Was this war really a complete
surprise, an unprovoked,
unpredictable act?
Or was it an outcome that was
actually foreseen, maybe even
cultivated and ultimately
provoked?
Was that fuse lit long before
the explosion?
That's the question we're left
to think about.